okay it's a pleasure
I did so I modified things a little bit
it's extremely close
so not that much is different
ah
yes we'll get some puns in
this is a good topic for funds by the
way so just throwing it out there so
it's a real pleasure to be speaking to
you today excited uh about some work
that my group has been excited with
about uh this line of work on coming up
with better ways to
build machine learning models that can
be aligned with human preferences and
what algorithmic questions are sort of
hidden in these kinds of problems
so this is work with uh excellent
excellent students Zach at Stanford uh
hentow who is a undergrad at Illinois at
the time where we worked on this
so uh set up the problem
so this is a problem of uh uh inverse
decision Theory it's motivated by a view
that comes from psychology
so here the idea is we want to
understand how human beings model other
humans decision making
and the theory or hypothesis is that one
way that we do this is that we ask uh
are we in we sort of collect a few
examples of decision outcomes and based
on these few examples uh we set up some
inference of sort of how others might be
making decisions and so this becomes our
model for other people's decision making
in machine learning problems uh there's
a way to formalize this as a kind of
human machine interaction problem and
I'll talk to that a little bit so the
idea is uh suppose you're in a setting
where the machine has some model that
sort of uh
uh you can think about this as has the
model of the property of the label given
inputs uh really what you need is
something calibrated uh to ground truth
but for Simplicity suppose it actually
has this conditional probability model
the machine knows this but doesn't know
the decision making so decision making
thought of here is a deterministic for
an inputs here as a label
um and so the goal is that the machine
will come up with an interaction process
with a human
that will help it infer the
decision-making role
um given only a few examples
um generally this is set up so that uh
uh decision making rule is uh optimal
for some measure over this population
over this setting
um the measure may be implicit or
explicit
we imagine that sort of the human has
some notion of optimal decision making
potentially implicit in this setting uh
that's tied to the underlying
conditional probabilities
and the Machine doesn't know this but
all it can do is sort of get a few
samples based on these samples try to
infer a decision making
and so this is the sort of uh
challenging piece here is that you only
get to see a few examples of these pairs
um if you want to connect this to some
other lines of work and uh that are out
there you can think about this as a
actually very explicitly a special case
of uh the idea of uh pre-training and
then fine-tuning based on interaction so
it's sort of very much in that style of
work so popular and say language models
but this will be quite far from it it
should be a setting where we can give
formal bounds on sort of sample
complexity and things like that
the query complexity but it's a the same
style of problem of sort of there exists
some initial process that may be learned
uh modeling distribution for the data
and now I want to convert this into a
classification that's of optimal for
some Metric that I may not know and if
you think about this as some decision
making rule
okay so uh
you can show that this question
um of trying to find a decision making
rule tied to this conditional
probability
if I think about it from a population
decision making point of view uh
this inverse decision Theory problem can
be reduced to a threshold search Problem
uh so you might be familiar with this
for instance and standard binary
classification you might know that if I
know the population distribution P of Y
given X then the optimal for accuracy is
uh pressuring out of half and if there's
a different metric it turns out that
sort of for most metrics the optimal
decision looks like some kind of
thresholding where thresholds might be
at different places
um and so uh this question of finding
the decision making rule under this
framework can be reduced to finding the
right threshold from the conditional
probability model to the decision making
model you might
immediately have some concerns about
gaps instead of the framing uh we'll
come to this in a second and some some
of the work that we do try to narrow the
Gap from this model to what we think of
as more realistic settings
the other thing to mention is that
um if you're thinking one way to try to
solve this problem is to think about
this as a search Problem
uh where uh you're trying to search for
the right threshold and every time you
get a label for an example
this label gives you some information
about where the threshold might be so if
the label is tied to a probability
that's uh large and it's a zero then it
maybe suggests that the threshold is
sort of kind of high conversely if it's
sort of small uh and it's a one then
maybe the threshold is sort of really
low in the setting so uh the label that
you get for a particular example tells
you something about what a thresher
might be and as you get additional
labels
um you might imagine sort of a search
process that moves a threshold around
following the labels
so uh seeing as a search problem you can
use a variety of search methods one good
approach one that will use as sort of
foundation of the work that we do is a
probabilistic bisection algorithm so
essentially by section search it allows
for uncertainty
so we have a slightly uh more General
version of this problem uh which we call
a Cooperative inverse decision Theory
and the reason we set it up this way
um there's sort of two ways to think
about it one is just existing gaps in
the IDC framework that we try to fill
and I'll talk to those briefly another
is thinking about this uh and this way
ties it to we think some useful framings
and useful applications
so uh
from the pure Gap point of view one way
to think about this is uh existing IDT
is I framed it as passive it just
collects examples and sort of tries to
convert that into a decision
um there's a bunch of uncertainty that
can show up that uh the existing tool
doesn't capture so in particular various
kinds of noisiness
diversity of opinion if you're doing
this kind of inference over a population
um missing or additional context that
either is information that the model or
the human has that's different that
might show up as noisiness
so some of our work is trying to fill in
this Gap
um so we think about this as a game
between a machine and a human
the machine we call it imitator so the
goal of the imitator is to try to infer
again this decision rule uh we'll start
off with thresholding rules and most of
this discussion will focus on
thresholding rules because again they're
quite General and capture lots of
different Notions of what good decision
making is
um so so General enough to be
practically useful
and the human is thought of as a
demonstrator so the human is showing the
machine uh again examples uh and
potential decision outcomes and the goal
again of the machine the imitator is to
try to figure out the sort of the
decision making that's closest to the
humans
so you can try to solve this by again
trying to learn a threshold the decision
rule
um as mentioned earlier both are trying
to maximize some Metric again directly
coupled so does this uh effectively
one-to-one I'm being a bit informal but
I can sort of talk to details or send
references offline of connections
between metrics and thresholds
and the actual process that this will go
through is that uh the imitator will
pick an example to query
but this is the active bit
um but doesn't know the performance
metric that's sort of the goal is to
optimize and the human the demonstrator
will respond however they like uh
hopefully matching their decision making
process uh such that then the decision
making function can be inferred okay
setup is clear
yes
what to show I think it's all the second
that's a good question so the question
is is there a difference uh who's
picking the example that's going to be
occurring uh in this case either the
machine or the human
um so we focus on it's a good question
actually okay uh the existing work
thinks of the queries is random the work
we do thinks of the machine picking the
queries under some sort of active
learning style method I think it's a
very interesting question of uh what
does this look like if the human is
picking the queries under some notion of
uh either ease or optimality or
something like that that's a great
question actually I don't have an answer
to that question that's an interesting I
get to think about
yeah any other questions
yes related to that would be
um
can the human modify the query slightly
so the question is can a human modified
a prairie I won't answer the questions
yeah uh we allow a short answer we don't
have that in the setup uh we allow for
and I'll talk a bit about sort of
settings where
they have different information this is
not the same as your question it's not
an explicit multiplication
[Laughter]
like I said this is a good topic for fun
so have fun okay any other questions
okay okay so I'll throw an algorithm up
here this is how you might do this with
uh the PBA algorithm this um bisection
search algorithm so quickly walking
through it
um the way that you might uh this is not
that maybe helpful in very short order
but uh maybe by pictures
so one way that we can uh solve this and
what you can do with a probabilistic
bisection search is you can start off
with some prior over
um possible threshold locations and you
can do effectively like uh
pseudo Bayesian updates is what we
explicitly do
um
it's not fully for technical reasons but
close
um and so you essentially sort of builds
a likelihood of a possible locations
of the threshold uh based on the queries
and then the active bit is being able to
figure out where to search and research
at points of sort of uh if you're
looking for say the median potential
threshold location then we use that to
define the threshold point to search the
way the algorithm actually works is that
this threshold uh this threshold points
so this probability points converted
into an example uh by sort of searching
for the example that matches that
threshold uh and then human gives a
response to that query that query
response is then sort of uh gives
directional information about whether
the threshold is to the right or to the
left of the query point this is used to
update the Bayesian model effectively
and then over over sequences you can
show that you'll converge to sort of
a ball around
the true threshold under this model
that's the setup
okay so fairly straightforward algorithm
it's worth pointing out uh some
properties of both this problem and how
it ties to some other existing work
so uh first uh you can show that for
this problem the optimal joints policy
is this by section search uh approach or
at least by second search is optimal
um
you we find and I'll talk about this a
little bit more
that uh some of the key differences from
at least classic active learning as it
applied to this problem uh are some of
the Notions of uncertainty that crop up
uh in this setting and so one of the
ones that we identify is something we
call the description experience Gap it's
also been noted by all the people and
I'll talk about this a little bit
some initial simulations to try to
understand a little bit better
and uh explicitly how it ties to
uncertainty and uh preferences and
decision making
okay and as mentioned about the
algorithm so again the idea is that
we're going to update the potential
location of the optimal threshold
um and this boils down to tracking the
measure of an Epsilon ball around yatmo
and is something you can analyze that
sort of how quickly you are
uh what the probability mass is on this
Epsilon ball or on the optimal
um and you define a stopping time by the
first time this measure exceeds a half
and this allows you to make uh sort of
high confidence decision on where the
threshold is
um and and the analysis we can upper
bound this process and use this to uh
say something about convergence of this
algorithm
a bit on the uncertainty because I think
that's some of the most interesting
aspects of this work
so uh there are lots of sources of
uncertainty we have a subset that we
analyze explicitly so one is noise so
the human
uh is potentially noisily optimal
there's some assumptions here of course
that uh uh again the humans decision
process is some uh is well modeled by a
thresholded uh so or since either you
can think about this as the optimizing
uh some Metric under knowledge of the
population distribution this is one way
to say it or you can think about it as
sort of uh sorry said slightly better
they're well calibrated in how they're
going from distributions of labels to
decisions so the calibration bit is
what's important showing up there all
you can think about this as
sort of oh some version of this model is
a reasonable model for the human
decision making process we'll show that
uh at least some that some ways that
this assumption breaks can be well
modeled or captured by noise
um and I'll talk to a nice model in a
second but again you could imagine noise
as being an issue with the framing so
far
um another setting that the presented
approach will handle well is uh decision
making when instead of inferring
information from a single human you want
to infer over a group of individuals and
so the idea is you want some kind of
consensus decision over a group and
again if uh under some assumptions that
I'll mention briefly
you can apply the same algorithm because
this will look from the point of view of
the algorithm a sort of noisy decision
making across noise across the
individuals so again as long as all of
them uh are making decisions again
roughly calibrated to conditional
probability of the label
and then we'll talk briefly about sort
of systematic differences between the
human and the Machine again in cases
where these can be captured well by uh
by this framework
so a bit on the systematics of
optimality one way that we think about
it is maybe the simplest case in where
this could happen is when uh the
features
that the human and the Machine are using
are different
so uh for instance it's actually
commonly true that human decision making
uh
uh I guess we often try to approximate
using machine learning models based on
features but our features are all
abstractions that don't fully cover so
all the aspects of the decision making
process and so there might be some gap
between even if all the assumptions are
true say humans are actually making
decisions using this calibrated to some
true conditional probability
um there could still be a difference
between the probability model that the
human is using that a machine is using
because they just they have different
features and so this will look like
noise effectively because some of the
features are missing from one of the
other and so this is like additional
uncertainty on the condition of
probability model
um yeah so in particular in this case uh
the human will appear suboptimal respect
to the misfun machines point of view
um so we think about this as a
description experience Gap this has been
thought about some in the literature
there's a bit of work in the field
thinking about this
um it's uh for one particular instance
of this as a description experience Gap
so refers to differences between uh
decisions made based on description
versus base and experience one way to
think about this uh cases where it comes
up is
um
uh if you imagine querying a doctor for
what decisions they might make in terms
of uh say clinical decision making
diagnosis kinds of settings the answer
they give you if you describe a case
need not be the same as the answer they
give you they're actually solving like
diagnosing a real case in a real setting
and so there's a descriptive answer and
the real world answer are different one
way to think about what might be
different is the information content is
a little bit different again the
description is some formalization with
some small subset of features uh the
real world version is richer somehow and
again there's this Gap that's not
captured and the set of features that's
being measured
and so because of this uh the human can
behave quite differently
um in this kind of assistive game given
that the nature of the queries come as
descriptions of examples so look like
features essentially
okay
um so the effect that you might imagine
uh of this is that the human will adjust
this decision role because again it has
a different underlying model
um
and some of what we can show in details
in the paper is that uh this will lead
to uh
sort of changing the nature of decision
threshold either sharper or less sharp
um and I'll actually skip ahead a little
bit so one way to think about this
is that um instead of thinking of the
decision rule as a straightforward
threshold which is maybe this example
and what you might uh what we've set up
as the model for this setting so again
we have an underlying conditional
probability we have a threshold as a
decision making process uh one way to
describe this a one one model that uh we
found meaningful for capturing this Gap
and many other kinds of noisy
um
noisy decision making settings it's
thinking about this as uh again still a
threshold of decision but now the
threshold is uh randomized so and that's
um instead of having a single threshold
you have a distribution over thresholds
and we can show that this model is
sufficient for instance to capture the
setting where the sets of features
differ between two decision makers and
they're interacting in order to make a
decision
so uh if you like the Gap in probability
modeling will can be captured by just uh
a distribution over possible thresholds
which is what is shown here and so this
is the sharpness idea that I was trying
to capture
um a little bit more formally uh we have
an approach that works uh generally
what we call uh or the range of settings
that we try to capture well are settings
where uh decision making process is
cumulative so this is thought of as a
bit richer than uh the pure threshold
and decision making process
the cumulative we mean that the expected
value of the decision is a monotone
function of the threshold so it's sort
of a weaker condition than uh pure
threshold it can itself be a random
variable
and roughly the key takeaway and a
property that we'll exploit is that if
the decision making process is
cumulative in a way they're describing
here then we can model it as uh decision
making with a randomized threshold so
that's the main takeaway of this line
okay
um so as mentioned this is a
non-realizability issue again this gap
between what the model has
and what the human decision making is
and this Gap can be well modeled um in
many settings but again this randomized
threshold
okay so the actual algorithm uh can
change a little bit to capture more
noisy settings
so for instance uh here's an
implementation of the algorithm
um that allows for uh noisiness so the
main change here is that instead of the
PBA algorithm that takes sort of a
single vote and uses this to make a
decision uh the
information about where the threshold
should be is now set up as a test so we
have a voting process here that sort of
you can think of
a bunch of different ways you can think
about it as just testing whether
uh H is equal to one or zero because
it's now random or you can think about
it as I guess directly as voting but uh
the main thing that we need and the main
thing that we employ for uh both the
algorithm and the analysis is that now
there's some confidence level that gets
tied to obtained signals this confidence
level is obtained by either setting is
up again as a test or voting
sufficiently so you sort of uh query
sufficiently often so to talk through
some examples you have a group then
you'll sample the group enough times to
have confidence Alpha in uh the decision
for the group the median decision for
the group uh if you have an individual
with noisy process again you might query
multiple times because again this looks
like Randomness in a decision
Okay so
um we have some results I'm gonna just
talk through the sort of high level one
if we have time I might cover some of
the other details but anyways
um one of the results here is that if
you have the class of models that we've
outlined so this uh class of models that
again well captured by
um randomized thresholds which you think
of as
richer than existing work and then Rich
enough to capture lots of interesting
phenomena and as long as the confidence
is sufficiently high so greater than
half
um then uh using this pseudo-basion
updates
in the way that I just described using
the algorithm allows you to show
convergence of this algorithm so
prevention of the threshold to the
optimal threshold
a lot more threshold
so the analysis is close to existing
analyzes of the PBA algorithm
um we have a modification that uses a
random walk argument that again I'll
invite you to look in a paper form more
details on
um and the main takeaway is that uh if
the noise is not too bad the algorithm
uh sort of doesn't suffer all that much
I feel like that's the main one way to
think about the main takeaway
a little bit on uh
the analysis again quite high level but
again we're trying to capture this
Epsilon ball around the optimal and sort
of how it updates over the sequence of
the algorithm you could show that you
can model it well as a geometric random
walk
and then we just need to understand the
stopping time to understand convergence
of this algorithm so that's the main
tool that we use
okay
um a little bit on experiments so we do
a few simulation experiments to try to
understand how this method Works instead
of pseudo-realistic settings
so the first one I'm showing here is uh
uh comparing the cidt method to uh IDT
the main difference is again the
existing approach uses passive
algorithmically one of the main
differences is that the existing
approach is passive samples whereas a
cidt activated queries for the next
sample
the other big difference is again noise
tolerance compared to the previous
approaches
here we're comparing log error of the
threshold compared to the optimal
showing that effectively think about
this as an active learning kind of plot
so it's showing that using active
querying increases uh accuracy much
quicker than doing this passive one
we also looked at
um the other kinds of different kinds of
noise and how this might affect uh
decision rule recovery so pseudo
simulated setting uh first we have on
the left the noisy setting so the noise
setting here is simple constant noise
the decision is flipped with the
probability 0.5 to capture some
uncertainty in decision making decision
makers process
um so simple constant noise and what I'm
showing is both the underlying uh sort
of uh decision likelihoods so
probability decision equals one for this
problem and comparing it to
um
quantiles of
uh quantiles of the estimated threshold
so I skipped a little bit in the past I
should briefly outline here so the way
the algorithm works we get to pick uh
what's quantity one estimate about the
distribution of thresholds uh and all
the algorithmic examples I I put up we
used a half to estimate the median
effectively but you can pick you can
choose any uh
any quantile you like this allows you to
estimate the whole distribution as
opposed to the single point of the
thresholders you can estimate the whole
distribution of uh thresholds in the
case of it as a noisy threshold that's
the main takeaway here
okay so we do this to show that again
this works for choosing like if I'm
interested in either modeling the whole
distribution or I'm interested in
potentially different points for uh
threshold decision yeah I can capture
this
um and different kinds of noise on the
left it's a constant noise label flip on
the right is a randomized decision
threshold it's a setting where again the
decision matches uh the expectation is
monotonic respect to conditional
probability but then it's sort of
randomized after that so modeling this
idea that we have a pool of decision
makers and we're sampling from them
okay
um we also have examples capturing this
idea that uh there might be different
subset of features for the decision
maker and the algorithm so again a sort
of a simulation approximating this
description experience Gap and we show
that well one there's some effects this
looks like noise this ends up
lengthening uh
instead of probably a decision being
this sharp threshold thing it now looks
like a much lengthened because there's
now a distribution over possible
decisions
um but we're able to capture it
reasonably well uh in this setting
we have some real data experiments so
yes okay oh okay so real data
experiments uh not real people but real
data so
a standard data set this is important as
you might imagine okay that's fine I'll
finish quickly and have time for
questions
um so we model this to again capture
this idea of different kinds of
information so we include uh
different feature subsets uh for the
decision maker versus the algorithm and
measure the absolute value difference
between let's say the threshold and then
the optimal threshold assuming that the
optimal decision or what we're
optimizing for is accuracy so Optimum
threshold for a half and we show what
happens with different versions of the
algorithm compared to the existing
approach which is the IDT both passive
and then doesn't capture or handle noise
appropriately
okay so to summarize uh some the main
contribution here is cooperative inverse
decision Theory approach which is meant
uh or designed to be a framework for
um
helping to
capture human preferences in machine
decisions in this particular setting
where we're interested in uh the gap
between probability models of the world
and then actual decision making
processes particularly when they're
noisy we've analyzed uh
uh an approach this sort of randomized
search approach with sort of testing in
the loop showing that it does pretty
well we have some analysis in the paper
so invite you to take a look for some
details and we've shown that uh in
capture a lot of the nuances of
different kinds of noise processes that
we think uh might be meaningful for this
kind of problem so far we've mostly
focused on binary decision making so
everything here has been sort of
predicting label binary label so we're
extending this work to think about more
complex decision-making problems Beyond
binary predictions and we've done a few
user experiments but there's a lot of
space it's always the fun part of this
kind of work is all the real human
facing stuff so a lot more on that part
of the work okay I'll stop here if there
are questions
[Applause]
we have time for questions
so I have um I guess this is it's a
little bit in your uh going Beyond
binary but I was thinking why not think
about the discrepancy between the
features the descriptions and the actual
experiments as a sort of a decision that
you have to make on what features you're
sharing some sort of a constraint and I
can you know why because right now you
assume that you're asking for a cell
phone maybe asking for a sample in a
smaller feature
so make this explicit you can okay so
one good reason to do something like
this so the comment is uh this was Mike
um that you can imagine settings where
your design process explicitly selects
over both examples and subsets of
features yeah like when we ask usually
we ask certain features and that's what
we are asking and just make surprise
that that would be a discrepancy between
understanding your decision making
more and this kind of goes back to of
course my obsession with this zooming in
and getting high resolution as we get
interested yeah
um
yeah
um I think it's a good idea I guess out
of the box if one did this uh you expect
the method to still do reasonable things
exactly
um I'm curious if one can so this uh
isn't telling a strategy for how to sub
select the teachers to ask questions on
which they might be interesting
basically as you ask more questions
there is this ability to zoom in on more
sophisticated questions which the models
should capture in some sense and it will
be very pretty yeah I find this
intriguing so sort of uh allow for
noisier at the beginning and narrow down
as we get closer so that's how we learn
most of the times I think that's a very
reasonable idea so we haven't played
with this but next level that was my
related question how do you set up a
base in learning part but
so so like
sure
um so the algorithm yeah uh yeah so the
update rule right I mean doesn't it
depend on how quickly go faster how much
how many samples you need to learn
so what was my question
um the convergence will depend on
examples and we have uh I guess what I
showed it is asymptotic results we have
some finite samples so they're doing
paper
[Music]
um
um many years ago there was this paper
titled very provocatively human
automatic complexity by uh by Jerry Drew
uh collaborators
um and they were trying to see you know
can humans actually like do humans in
fact reject decision rules that just fit
noise and instead of zero in on on
informative decision rules and I I mean
I don't know what happened to that work
they they did they presented Europe so I
I think they just have some application
for Photograph science decision making
but it seems like you say yeah I I
vaguely remember the paper because I do
remember that uh yeah it was provocative
at this time I didn't think about it
when we were working on this I think
things are good to take a look you're
talking about more like active decision
making which them to be connected to
Sasha rocklin's work on sequential
automatically see now if you write a
paper for humans again
title configure rights itself basically
yeah it's like an award winning paper
thank you
[Applause]